- [Narrator] Should I say hi?
I don't wanna interact.
No one's paying attention, I
don't need to say anything.
But does that make me look anti-social?
Please don't sit next
to me, please don't sit.
Why is having another
person sit next to me
so uncomfortable?
I feel like they're too
close not to interact.
Shit, now we just stand here silently.
Oh god this is so awkward,
do I say something?
I'll just watch the floors change.
I'll go later.
K? Just K?
Did I say something wrong?
Maybe she wants to have lunch later?
- Go ahead and tell the team your idea.
- [Narrator] Everyone's looking at me.
My heart is pounding.
They can probably tell I'm nervous.
Ah, that's so embarrassing.
- Hey come meet the new hire.
- [Narrator] Do I go for a handshake?
A hug? Do I just wave?
- Oh hey, do you wanna come out tonight?
Everyone's going.
- [Narrator] Ah, I think
I'm just gonna go home.
- Ah lame.
- [Narrator] God, I am lame.
They probably hate me,
think I'm super anti-social.
When do I wave?
Am I too far to wave?
I think my palms are sweating.
Hi.
- It was so great catching up with you,
I'll see ya later.
- Wow, that was nice.
I really think that went okay.
(soft music)